so I actually had no idea Sunday night
when I was preparing the Monday show
that I would end up talking so much
about impeachment this week but every
single day the number of prominent
Democrats and legal experts who are
saying impeachment is justified
impeachment is the correct thing
impeachment debate at minimum if not
proceedings should actually start right
away that number of people is growing
and growing so every day I find myself
with with sort of more to discuss about
this and I don't want to sort of like
rehash the entire list for you every
single day in order to build on it but
I'll remind you that Elizabeth Warren
now says that she believes impeachment
of Donald Trump is the right thing there
is a growing number of people some of
whom I'll add to that list today who are
saying this and the point is it's a
movement that is gaining momentum at
this point in time and it's really
important to talk about the distinction
between starting a debate on impeachment
in the House of Representatives and
actually filing impeachment proceedings
which would be a sort of formal
investigation culminated by a vote by
members of the Senate about whether the
president should or should not be
removed the mere start of debate about
impeachment would allow a whole bunch of
documents to to be released the house
could debate and decide rather than to
impeach to censure for example and we
could talk about whether censuring
really has any sort of practical impact
on the President of the United States
from what I've been reading the last
couple of days the answer is basically
no but the point is deciding to start
debate about impeachment does not mean
that it must or definitely will
culminate in actual impeachment
proceedings and eventually a Senate vote
about whether or not to remove the
president and in fact there are people
saying have the debate but maybe go for
censure rather than impeachment but that
is all kind of secondary here and also
sort of increasingly secondary is the
discussion of impeachment is a strategy
I've been talking for more than a year
now about how impeachment as a political
strategy for 2020 or as a political
strategy for removing the president of
the United States is not particularly
useful and I got a lot of critiques over
the last few days
now that the sort of contours of this
impeachment discussion have changed
saying David forget about the strategy
of it for a second it's the duty of
Congress given the evidence that we have
to at minimum debate the impeachment of
the president if not actually file
impeachment proceedings and I want to
sort of focus along those lines today
I'll give you some examples of the
growing voices that are taking a point
of view on this that is very much Pro at
least starting debate on impeachment
Leonard Pitts jr. is a writer for the
Miami Herald who points out in a new
piece which were linking to that this is
not about strategy but that this is
about right and wrong and that every
corner of government has been corrupted
in some way the Justice Department with
William Barr the press relationship and
access to the White House visa vie Sarah
Huckabee Sanders endless endless lies
including some of which have now been
verified beyond any doubt it's not just
speculation that she lies it's actually
the Moller report says that she lies she
admitted to lying and he goes on to
explain how basically every corner of
government has been corrupted at this
point in time and it is time to impeach
congresswoman Maxine Waters a Democrat
saying straight up on MSNBC yesterday
we're going to have to impeach
congressman Elijah Cummings I told you
yesterday he was sort of of the mindset
of there should be consequences and if
not now when or what would justify
consequences type of statement to sang
on MSNBC yesterday congressman Elijah
Cummings that Trump quote deserves the
mark of impeachment so we're not talking
about strategy here we're talking about
right and wrong we're talking about a
congressional duty to do what it is that
they're supposed to do given the
circumstances and the evidence that we
have but there are also some interesting
strategy articles being released related
to impeachment one example is from
Republican strategist Cheri Jacobus who
argues that impeachment will actually
help Democrats now we'll get at the end
of the show today today's voicemail is
from an angry trumpet
who is sort of begging for Democrats to
try to impeach Trump Trump believing
that this will just help Trump get
reelected in 2020 that's one perspective
what sherry Jacobus is pointing out is
that most Americans many Americans a
plurality of Americans whatever phrase
you want to apply to it don't have any
idea what's in the molar report in other
words most people have lives most people
aren't watching long congressional
hearings even if the Michael Cohen
congressional hearing had record ratings
for such a hearing the molar report is
450 pages and to the extent that people
see a news story about it or
unfortunately get their impressions of
what's in the molar report from the bar
letter which is a complete sort of miss
miss characterization of what's in the
molar report that if you actually start
debate on impeachment and move forward
on impeachment even if it doesn't
succeed at removing the president it
will inform people about the content of
the Moller report it will inform people
who have no idea what is actually going
on what it is that is being debated and
that has taken place and that in the
long run it will actually help Democrats
and hurt Donald Trump as we approach the
2020 election now should Democrats take
advice from a Republican strategist
maybe not
you also have Harvard Law Professor
Lawrence tribe who is for sure a
partisan actor but he is someone who
knows a lot about impeachment who says
at this point in time Donald Trump is
impeachable and by that he means
actually removable by a Senate vote on
the basis of impeachment proceedings
started by the house so the last five
days we've seen a very decided shift
here you've seen more and more Democrats
sort of abandoning the Nancy Pelosi
perspective of we shouldn't bother with
him with impeachment Trump's not worth
impeachment whatever other phraseology
she's applied to this since March you've
seen more and more momentum build
Democrats part ways with Nancy Pelosi
and what's clear at this point in time
without knowing exactly how this is
going to play out is that the discussion
about impeachment is not disappearing
next week and it's not disappearing next
month and
it's gone beyond the issue of political
strategy which I still believe to be
legitimate to one simply of given the
facts what is supposed to be Congress's
role in adjudicating the actions of the
President of the United States it's time
to start a floor debate on impeachment
and at that point in time once that has
happened Congress can decide do we want
to actually move forward with articles
of impeachment do we want to move
forward with censure of the president or
after this debate have we determined
that we're not going to go any further
that should be the immediate next step
and it goes well beyond political
strategy at this point in time today the
David Pakman show was made possible in
part by nord VPN which is a tool that
i've been using on my computer and my
phone to protect my privacy online and
to keep my personal data safe because it
allows you to change your device's IP
address making you totally anonymous on
the internet and Nord VPN is giving
everybody in our audience a 75% discount
on a three-year subscription this comes
out to less than three bucks a month
plus a whole month free when you go to
Nordby pn comm slash david pakman and
use the coupon code david pakman all one
word we know that the david pakman show
has a lot of viewers in Europe and
article 13 of the European Union
copyright directive was just passed
which has been an extremely
controversial piece of legislation among
the YouTube community because it
requires YouTube and other video sharing
platforms to crack down on copyright in
even harsher ways and there are still a
lot of unanswered questions about what
effects this law is going to have
YouTube videos might even be blocked in
Europe and this type of thing is
something else that Nord VPN is perfect
for if content is being censored where
you live Nord VPN lets you change your
IP address so that it looks like you're
connecting to the internet from a
totally different geographical location
and you circumvent these types of
heavy-handed content bans and censorship
but there's lots of other advantages as
well your
making yourself a lot less susceptible
to being hacked it makes it harder for
creepy social media websites to follow
you around the internet when you use
Nord VPN you and what you're doing
online stay totally anonymous and david
pakman show viewers can get 75% off a
three-year plan of Nord VPN that's under
three bucks a month plus one whole month
totally free just by going to Nord VPN
dot-com slash David Pakman I've put the
link underneath this video then just use
the coupon code David Pakman at checkout
all one word